[Musique]
et nous accueillons jean de gliniasty le
directeur de recherche à l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques
nicolas conc'air porte-parole des
républicains overseas france et yves
nidegger qui est avocat et
parlementaires suisses
il se trouve à genève bonsoir à vous
merci à d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france donc on a vu cet après midi
joe biden qui s'est entretenu avec les
dirigeants de l'union européenne avant
cela il ya eu un sommet de l'otan
l'union européenne l'otan les états unis
qui ont affiché une unité face à la
chine et la russie ensemble ils ont
dressé à des lignes rouges avant
d'évoquer avec vous justement ces lignes
rouges
est-ce que ce front commun il est
réellement solide jean de gliniasty
mais il faut dire que la diplomatie
américaine a travaillé aux petits points
on a commencé par le g7
ensuite il ya le temps après il ya les
l'union européenne et ça se termine en
apothéose avec que le sommet poutine by
them donc l'objectif c'est de réunir
tous les européens et et au delà même
sur la base d'une sorte de plate formes
démocratiques droits de l'homme et
resserré en fait les rangs d'une sorte
de camp occidental face à poutine pour
se présenter en position de force alors
les lignes rouges
on ne sait pas trop bien ce qu'elles
sont de part et d'autre le président
poutine sur le récit 24 à a annoncé par
exemple que l'adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'otan était une ligne rouge il l'a dit
dans le communiqué de l'otan il ya le
rappelle que l'ukraine a vocation à
rentrer à l'otan ce qui veut dire que
les lignes rouges 2 1 ne sont pas
forcément les lignes rouges des autres
et que finalement on sait pas trop où on
va mais on trouvera sûrement
moyen de de rassurer cette stabilité
dont le président byden parlait nicolas
comte est un tronc solide
l'union européenne les états unis et
l'otan l'otan parce que cette question
parce qu'au sein de l'otan il ya aussi
la turquie et on sait qu'il ya beaucoup
de deux points de crispation avec ankara
notamment avec la france avec la grèce
et la situation en méditerranée
orientale la touques est tout de même un
allié de la russie notamment dans le
processus d'astana en syrie
effectivement on voit que dans la prise
de position de baden qui clame que
america is back
de notre côté chez les républicains on
considère que c'est un changement de
paradigme total par rapport à la
politique menée par trump qui était plus
isales sioniste non interventionniste et
pas en faveur d'un monde multipolaire
on connaît en droit de se demander
qu'est ce qui a de géopolitique et
géostratégie derrière ces alliances qui
sont un peu bancal et sur lesquelles on
n'a pas de vue claire des des
contreparties et les concessions qui
vont être offertes on voit surtout que
là il ya des gages qui sont donnés à la
russie sans contrepartie et qui rendent
dépendant aussi bien en europe de
l'ouest les états unis par rapport au
gaz et au pétrole russe et sur
l'ensemble des décès des mesures lancées
par la politique de bingen sur la levée
des sanctions contre l'iran comme gage
de bonne foi c'est pas ça qui va lui
permettre de réassurer le statut de
superpuissance des états unis et donc
pour conclure on voit qu'au bout de cinq
mois dans l'administration buydens
présente affaibli et pas en mesure de
tenir face fener tête face à baye dunn
et face à poutine yves nidegger vous
êtes à genève en territoire neutre si on
peut parler ainsi joe biden il a promis
de dire à vladimir poutine qu'elle était
pour lui
pour les occidentaux les lignes rouges
on imagine qu'il ya évidemment des
dossiers de crispation mais ce qui peut
se permettre à votre avis vous qui êtes
parlementaires suisses de prendre le
risque de s'ériger en donneur de leçon
ou en réalité il va vite se faire
rattraper par la real politique et
finalement se positionner des galets
le face au chef du kremlin
je crois que le son c'est plutôt la
chose qu'il faut cesser de faire il me
semble que la tournée qu'il a entreprise
pour monsieur baden en europe maintenant
participe essentiellement de la question
chinoise et du rôle qui peut être dévolu
à la russie dans cette nouvelle guerre
froide qui oppose principalement là des
états unis à la chine s'ils devaient
faire une comparaison j'ai des
journalistes à l'époque j'étais jeune en
85 lorsque reggane gorbatchev se
retrouvaient à genève aujourd'hui c'est
pas ça aujourd'hui c'est plutôt l'or a
comparé lorsque nixon la rencontre
qu'elle cheminait en 72 parce que traits
brouillés avec l'union soviétique il
essaye de retourner les chinois on est
un petit peu cette situation là
aujourd'hui s'agit de trouver un
équilibre dans lequel la russie qui est
un pays occidental aurait un rôle à
jouer mais pour ça il faudrait quand
même commencer par les retards sur le
fait que les etats-unis reconnaissent à
la russie sa position et son existence
et là il ya un profond malentendu le
pire dans sept domaines c'était quand
même les démocrates avec monsieur obama
disait la fédération de russie séquelles
pib déjà on a peu considéré du point de
vue américain
parfois du côté européen aussi
l'importance géopolitique l'importance
pour l'économie du futur d'une puissance
aussi territorialement aussi importante
et étendue que la fédération de russie
or on faisait allusion à la chine jean
de gliniasty d'après l'hebdomadaire
russe experts le président américain il
ne souhaiterait pas que la russie
justement bascule décidé tivement dans
le camp chinois
ça c'est un enjeu important selon vous
c'est un enjeu très important et c'est
la carte essentielle les russies faso
aux américains sur tous les autres
points les russes ont plutôt mon
position de faiblesse sur faiblesse
disons militaire en tout cas
on peut le considérer malgré les armes
nouvelles ils sont en état de faiblesse
et économique
ils sont actuellement enfin belgacom en
partie réussi son coup de réunir le camp
occidental donc poutine aborde
normalement ce débat en position de
faiblesse mais il a une carte formidable
c'est qu'en fait les américains ont
besoin de lui pour face à la chine c'est
à dire que les américains souhaitent que
la russie ne bascule pas complètement du
côté chinois et c'est ça la carte
maîtresse de poutine nicolas comte air
des lignes rouges pour les occidentaux
on imagine cela faire alexeï navalni
l'ukraine aussi mais du côté russe on ne
veut pas d'ingérence a certes un bon
comment on va se débrouiller de demain
joe biden justement bat déjà il est
important de remettre en place le niveau
disposition sur le new start qui permet
de légiférer sur les armes des arbres et
puissent ensemble en place la deuxième
chose ça va être enfin pour les russes 2
de voir qu'il ya un front commun unit et
s'élever face à l'hyper puissance de la
chine qui nécessite que byden puisse
réunir le club comme l'appelait macron
aujourd'hui autour autour d'un large
front commun alors le new start
effectivement ce sont des intérêts
mutuels auquel se montre très attaché
vladimir poutine on va en parler mais il
veut nidegger sur la relation entre les
deux hommes
puisque vous êtes agenais avec cette
rencontre elle va se dérouler là bas est
ce que vous pensez
demain qu'on va voir une accolade entre
les deux hommes
ou bien une simple poignée de main
finalement assez froide
pas ce qui est prévu c'est ans via des
conférences de presse séparées alors
président que les choses évolueront
grâce à l'atmosphère suisse qui est
d'une grande chaleur si on plonge tout
le monde dans la fondue mais ce qui est
au départ c'est une position d'hostilité
quand je comparais avant avec nixon et
twilight crois que c'est un peu ça on
part d'un constat d'une opposition
fondamentale et de la nécessité de
rétablir à nouveau parce que le monde a
changé
des relations qui sont un peu plus
constructive
les etats-unis ne peuvent pas faire sans
la russie je pense et la russie aspirent
depuis longtemps à être à prendre sa
place au fond dans le monde occidental
si on se rappelle en 85 d'ici la
discussion entre garonne et gorbatchev
je me souviens assez bien dans l'idée de
berbatov
sylla l'union soviétique cesser d'être
hostiles à l'occident l'otan devaient
disparaître au fond n'avait plus sa
raison d'être
et puis deuxième ligne si l'allemagne se
réunifier alors elle devait être neutre
et ne devait pas être ni dans le temps
ni dans le pacte de varsovie
résultat des courses l'allemagne s'est
réunifiée l'otan est resté l'allemagne
tout entière est entré dans le temps et
pire encore les frontières le thon rouge
et pour inclure la roumanie la bulgarie
et maintenant il ya un clash sur
l'ukraine à mon avis si on ne règle pas
cette question de zones d'influencé
respecter des deux côtés entre l'otan et
la fédération de russie
il sera compliqué de donner un rôle à la
russie dans le grand plan américain
d'une stabilisation des choses est que
chacun trouve un équilibre dans ce monde
multipolaire dont on parle en théorie
mais qui n'a encore pas trouvé ses
marques
jean de gliniasty sat rencontre allait
être important sur le fond mais sur la
forme aussi en reviens à ma question
on sait que joe biden a accusé
la dmr boutines de tueurs au delà des
mots justement joe biden qui a été le
premier à lancer des piques
est ce qu'il va faire un geste amical
art ravir envers athènes maintenant
c'est très difficile à dire
je crois que ce que ce que chacun attend
ces quelques éléments déterminants pour
l'établissement d'une relation stable et
prévisible comme on dit des deux côtés
d'ailleurs concernant un certain nombre
de dossiers importants dont le
désarmement dont on a parlé dont
probablement une sorte d'ordre
cybernétique pour éviter les attaques
probablement certaines questions climat
avirons et alors la question que les
russes n'arrive pas à comprendre
n'arrive pas et une alfa en déterminer
l'importance pour les états unis
la question des droits de l'homme et qui
sera probablement la question la plus
difficile mais sur le reste il ya un
agenda et je crois que des deux parties
et deux parties ont envie de d'obtenir
un résultat effectivement pour une
situation plus prévisible et plus stable
donc les à partir de là les aspects
protocolaires voir les mots un peu fort
prononcé les uns contre les autres dans
le passé en fait à vrai dire c'est que
les américains au prononcé ces mots là
c'est un moins d'importance alors les
points de les points de convergence
il ya la prééminence pour joe biden de
sur la limitation des armements sur les
autres dossiers c'est un point très
important et c'est un point commun aussi
avec vladimir poutine la prolongation du
traité new start iii n'est qu'on l'a pas
encore bien sûr il ya quelque chose à
poursuivre qui a été initiée sous
administration de donald trump
on peut parler également d'autres points
de convergence qui vont être la lutte
contre le terrorisme et le crime
organisé de poursuivre un petit peu les
travaux qui ont été menés conjointement
entre la cia et salés sucrés rieuse qui
ont permis d'empêcher des attentats en
2007 à saint-pétersbourg souvent des
villes russes mais également de citoyens
américains
et il ya également un point de fractures
ou sur lesquels il va falloir s'imposer
du côté maiden c'est de lutter fermement
contre tout ce qui sont donc les
cyberattaques qui provoque voilà des
dommages et des dégâts sans précédent et
qui doivent être considérés tout comme
une attaque sur la souveraineté d'un
état souverain
il venait d'ailleurs justement est-ce
qu'il va falloir trouver l'équilibré
entre ces points de divergence et puis
ces points de convergence aussi ça va
être un peu compliqué pour les deux
parties demain
oui ça sera compliqué c'est le monde qui
a besoin d'un nouvel équilibre et ce
monde est encore cet équilibre être
encore à dessiner il vient d'être fait
état d' des cyberattaques et de sons de
choses lorsque une partie à la
discussion est en position qu'elle
estime être de faiblesse généralement
elle vend sa capacité de nuisance à la
question des cyberattaques c'est
typiquement ça les chinois ils font
d'ailleurs parfois aussi consistante à
dire écoutez on peut cesser de vous être
style mais il faudrait nous traiter bien
je crois que c'est tout ce qui va se
faire demain pour le reste c'est
effectivement comme ça a été dit
beaucoup de la rhétorique monsieur byden
dans la même semaine a trouvé le moyen
de traiter monsieur poutine de tueurs
d'une part et de traiter la suisse de
paradis fiscal d'autre part lorsque j'ai
vu monsieur par mail à notre président
et qui m'a demandé ce qu'il fallait dire
à monsieur wade lui et souhaite je vais
suggérer de dire bienvenue au paradis et
de lui remettre une copie que ça
derrière taxation fiscale
alors il ya quand même un dossier
important c'est le projet north stream
ii le gazoduc qui relie la russie à
l'allemagne auquel est attaché berlin
c'est certes un bon c'est que les états
unis ils sont plutôt hostiles
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à un
compromis de la part de joe biden demain
jean de gliniasty
s'il ya un complot messieurs
compromission nord stream
ça sera un compromis essentiellement
entre l'allemagne et les états unis et
la suspension de certaines sanctions sur
le stream est le résultat de contact qui
ont déjà eu lieu entre madame merkel
les allemands mal côté et les américains
de l'autre donc comme l'allemagne est
considéré par les etats-unis comme un
des piliers de leur politique européenne
la négociation a dit j'ai tendance à
penser a déjà eu lieu d'ailleurs dans
les semaines qui ont précédé
on a vu que le tube
le gazoduc a été terminée matériel mort
donc c'est la question qui se pose
maintenant c'est ce qu'on met en
fonction
donc je pense que sur ce plan
l'essentiel de la négociation a déjà eu
lieu entre à la merkel et monsieur by
them nicolas conteste instinct dossier
quand même qui sommes un peu la zizanie
au sein de l'union européenne ce projet
nord stream
deux questions majeures dont certains
tenants sont éludées notamment les liens
du fondateur et pdg de daon string et
matthias warnig qui a un ancien collègue
du kgb de poutine et qui montre bien un
peu les imbrications entre entre ce
projet politique est vraiment une
influence géopolitique dans cette zone
en rendant tous ces pays d'europe de
l'ouest dépendant énergétiquement donc
au bon vouloir des russes donc c'est
vraiment se mettre dans des situations
vraiment très très critique et ça
nécessite à ce que l'admiration de by
dane puissent prendre des sanctions à la
hauteur de ce qui a pu être pris à
l'égard de gazprom par exemple pour
lutter contre toutes ces indications de
l'économie en pouvoir et inversement
on est vraiment alors mettre fin alors
la stabilité stratégique l'encadrement
la non prolifération nucléaire bon ça va
être des points sur lesquels évidemment
on va entendre les deux chefs d'état est
ce qu'il faut s'attendre à des
engagements concrets demain à votre avis
yves nidegger
je n'en sais strictement rien je connais
pas la liste des choses qui doivent être
discutée demain on n'a pas envoyé de
copies est ce qu'il y aura des
engagements je pense qu'on a affaire à
une rencontre de type plutôt symbolique
qui devrait marquer à cause du
changement l'administration américaine
aussi un type de relation qu'on espère
différents ensuite il ya tous les
éléments concrets qu'ils ne changeront
pas la dépendance en matière d'énergies
fossiles de l'europe occidentale face à
la russie mais aussi la grande faiblesse
militaire de l'union européenne union
européenne a pas véritablement de
défense est une des questions que se
posent les européens c'est ce que vous
préférez obéir aux russes qui ont une
armée ou aux turcs y en a une aussi
et qui sont les deux seuls entre nous et
la chine les rapports sont des rapports
de force ils sont tout sauf agréable à
considérer l'union européenne est en ce
moment on est une très grande
vulnérabilité elle se pense porteuse de
valeurs universelles absolument
indétrônable en vérité sans sur le plan
militaire qu'énergétique aussi brillante
soit la civilisation d'europe
occidentale et de devoir composer avec
l'eurasie et la première étape de
l'eurasie pour nous c'était évidemment
la fédération de russie a juste pour
conclure en deux mots un jean de
gliniasty nicolas comte à rebours
rebondir à ce que disait tout à l'heure
à yves nidegger finalement joe biden il
va être à l'aise demain en foulant le
sol de ce paradis fiscal la suisse
oui tu vois qu'ici il est à l'aise
il aborde indéniablement oui il y eut
d'abord deux incontestablement la
situation en position de force il a
réuni tout son monde à l'otan même si
effectivement dessous il ya quelques
petites différences mais ne se sont pas
manifestés de façon évidente
donc il a un objectif précis c'est de
montrer notamment à son électorat que
négocient sérieusement et il obtient des
résultats
et comme le président poutine a aussi
besoin de montrer qu'il parle au monde
occidental donc nous sommes nous sommes
dans une situation est relativement
optimiste sur les résultats
vous êtes d'accord nicolas compteur pour
conclure je pense qu'on voit que baye
donne un peu la coqueluche et n'est
admis adulé on attend son à son arrivée
je pense que moi de mon côté un
américain ressortissants à l'étranger et
républicains le problème c'est pas
d'être aimé c'est que notre puissance
américaine soit respecté de par le monde
et ça ça nécessite de poser des actes
forts et de pas faire de compromis
notamment aux vis-à-vis des russes midi
les chinois est de pouvoir créer un
front commun reprendre la politique
initiée par donald trump qui consiste à
remettre les états unis centre du
dispositif est de mettre fin à
l'intervention
merci à vous un écho la con car
porte-parole des républicains aux vingt
six français jean de gliniasty directeur
de recherche à l'institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques et yves
nidegger avocat et parlementaires
suisses